on va continuer sur votre sondage
monsieur bourque christian bourque
vice-président exécutif associé chez les
jets bonsoir bonsoir c'est vraiment un
coup de sonde très intéressant un moment
précis vous avez réalisé ce sondage
auprès des canadiens auprès des
américains également du 11 au 13 mars
comment est ce que vous qualifiez la
préoccupation des gens face à
l'inflation
huit ménages sur dix se disent
préoccupés que c'est un problème sérieux
pour une inflation ce qui nous a marqué
aussi c'est que les deux tiers des gens
au travail nous disent mes revenus
l'augmentation mes revenus ne suis pas
en fait l'augmentation des prix que je
paye à l'épicerie ou ailleurs donc ils
s'estiment l'inflation à 5 % sont pas
tellement loin de la réalité et selon eu
leurs revenus ne seront pas à la
rencontre de cette augmentation la dcri
à la consommation oui donc est-ce que ça
aura un impact sur l'endettement des
ménages c'est ce qu'on va vouloir
commencer à suivre aussi le dans les
semaines qui viennent alors on va
regarder quelques-unes des questions
vous avez posé justement à la question
le revenu de votre ménage assez suivi le
rythme de l'inflation
63% monsieur bourque répondent que non
non mon revenu n'a pas suivi l'inflation
donc de là la grande préoccupation des
gens absolument et on le voyait tout à
l'heure votre collègue parlait de
certaines modifications des
comportements mais faux souvenirs dans
toute science du comportement que faire
changer des comportements fondamentaux
chez des adultes c'est relativement
difficile on fait souvent des
ajustements à la marge
donc est ce que c'est le
les économies qu'ils vont en souffrir
est ce que en revoir des gens qui vont
au moins mettre d'argent côté est-ce
qu'ils vont au contraire s'endetter
parce qu'essentiellement peut-être les
changements de comportements seront pas
suffisantes pour faire face à
l'inflation et parlons-en des
changements de comportement en raison de
la hausse de l'inflation quelles mesures
avez vous prises ou envisagez vous de
prendre c'est la question vous avez posé
les gens vont moins dépenser moins
dépenser duire le gaspillage alimentaire
acheter des articles moins chers à
l'épicerie dépenser moins pour les
articles ménagers manger au restaurant
on commande et moins souvent donc les
gens ce les gens les fonds les
changements oui souhaite les faire il y
en a qui nous préoccupe plus que
d'autres c'est à dire l'impact sur
l'industrie de la restauration on en
parlait tout à l'heure où si la
catégorie suivante c'était de réduire
les dépenses en divertissement le taux
de l'industrie du spectacle qui peine à
se remettre des deux dernières années va
peut-être aussi subir les contrecoups de
cette inflation là et aussi quand on
fait des choix moins cher à l'épicerie
pour la moyenne est très bien informée
on fait souvent des choix qui sont moins
bon pour notre santé à la dernière crise
économique aux états unis en 2008 2009
c'est les fruits et les légumes qui ont
écopé quand les gens ont voulu réduire
leur facture à l'épicerie c'est pas les
choix qu'on souhaite que les canadiens
fassent effectivement les gens sont si
on doit faire ce moment donné si c'est
trop cher c'est trop cher on prend on
prend un autre produit et dans les
autres descriptions qui avait l'envié de
remettre ce tableau l'homme et dans
celui là exactement réduire
l'utilisation de votre véhicule soixante
dix pour cent des gens sont prêts à
faire ça
oui alors que les gens se sont encore
plus éloignés de leur lieu de travail
durant la pandémie est-ce que ça doit
être possible est ce qu'ils seront en
mesure de le faire c'est peut-être
l'utilisation de la deuxième voiture qui
qui pourrait être une modification
comportementale qui est à la portée de
certains cas certainement de secret du
véhicule mais encore une fois c'est des
changements qui sont difficiles à faire
pour pour des ménages avec le train de
vie que c'est que les gens ont pas
facile de réduire de façon très
significative l'utilisation par exemple
de son véhicule monsieur beau que je
disais vous avez fait ce sondage aux
etats unis également et donc à la
question par exemple si on se projette
dans les six prochains mois et ça c'est
important sur le plan économique parce
que les anticipations d'inflation
s'ajoute à l'inflation en soi donc dans
quelle mesure pensez vous que
l'inflation les taux d'intérêt les prix
de l'essence vont monter de 84 à 86 %
des canadiens pensent que ça va
augmenter de 73 à 60 18 % des américains
il ya un écart quand même c'est
intéressant oui un écart les américains
on le voit en études de marché sont
habituellement plus optimiste que les
canadiens et s'il a un peu le reflet de
ce qu'on voit dans sondage ci mais les
majorités sont quand même assez écrasant
donc les gens ont l'impression que cet
oeuf sur l'oeuvre perdurer est-ce que
cela aura un impact sur des achats
plutôt à moyen terme ameublement
électroménager est ce qu on vouloir
retarder d achat ou faire ses achats à
crédit parce qu'on a l'impression que
l'inflation va être avec nous pour un
bout de temps donc les décisions
difficiles à venir le pur et vous diriez
que l'inflation est la préoccupation
première des canadiens même maintenant
bien bien devant un lac au vide
ah oui en fait c'est dans l'ordre c'est
l'inflation l'ukraine est ensuite
lakovic ok quand même donc ça reste
quand même une préoccupation mais on
voit que l'inflation préoccupe le
portefeuille de tout le monde christian
bourque c'est très intéressant sondage
vraiment révélateur merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir je vous en prie